welcome to a new edition of las
vegas in spanish cheers to natalia bad
luck today we start with a great
announcement from a mexican superstar i
am very excited about alejandro
fernández i am talking about and it is that he added
a second concert in the game break
word and  nerina part of his made in
mexico tour he will take prisoner on thursday
september 16 and celebrate
mexican independence day tickets for
this second date will be on sale
this friday
and the multitalented erc dance artist
has
just announced his residency at noble
med at the beni sensor starting on
september 22 the cost of the index tickets is
around 39 dollars and they go
on sale on monday july 26 in the
morning
and the band eighties journey comes to
las vegas for a special presentation
together with a  symphony on site you were
this december 18 you can get
your tickets from friday
morning
now an update related to  n
the residence of Bruno Mars and it is that
these concerts scheduled for this
Friday and Saturday had to be
postponed due rather to
unforeseen circumstances but listen
well if you already have tickets for these
dates do not worry that they have been
replaced for 27 and 28  august
now if for some reason you want a
refund these these will be honored
more until august 13th or if not the
sale is final
ok now let's heat up this segment a little bit
and talk about kuanip go with my
peña aka the
tribute artist  jennifer lópez this week
she threw a big party in honor of the
launch of her new project, the
first for her and that is that she has a
new song I had the opportunity to
interview on the red carpet of this
celebration
the rhythm has a little sound like
It's classic reggaeton but it also has
a bit of bachata sounds. It has the
instruments as a style, a fusion
between bachata and el  classic reggaeton
to very nice men I don't go out
with girls classic men I don't look for
adventure or the basics and I voted for my boyfriend
by the way I have
that is a look at the new song by
con y peña together here in a group a
Cuban artist who lives in the  vegas
but this new project is just the
beginning for this artist and it is that he
is also working on something very special with
the actor jimmy fallon in addition to
continuing his musical career
I am preparing the ipi with many more
songs with another very strong producer in
the industry who  he made the rhythm of gibalbín
you know here ters we have a song
that we are going to release next month
also called bury is a dembow the
same in Latin music so as not to
lose son twin otter overbooking el
frutero pérez pan and so is a little bit
of  Spanish so since you already heard the
new song by con and it doesn't come out until
August in the meantime you can listen to their
classic song and see this video on
youtube and in all the silver
good musical forms and before saying goodbye
I would like to wish you a happy
independence day for our
Colombian brothers who celebrated this
historic date on July 20 until it
came to your edition of the strikes in
Spanish thank you very much for your
attention see you next week  say hello
natalia bad sound
[Music]